with the latest covet variant soaring to
record highs president joe biden began
with a warning and i'll give it to you
straight as i promised to i always would
we're going to see as you all have been
hearing continued rise in cases
then in his address to the nation he
offered reassurance
if you're vaccinated and boosted you are
highly protected
you know
be concerned about omicron but don't be
alarmed
the omicron variant is surging setting a
single day record with more than a
million new infections overrunning test
centers leaving many more wondering if
they too are contagious
though less lethal than previous
variants omicron is more infectious
threatening to overrun hospitals and
threatening even children who are
largely unvaccinated covet in a very
short period of time has become one of
the leading medical causes of death
for children in this country
so i think it's about time that we
stopped downplaying the significance of
covid for children the explosive
contagion hit hardest in the u.s as
families gathered for the christmas
holiday season cancelling understaffed
flights and setting off a wave of
vaccine and re-masking mandates
across the u.s where positive coveted
tests have surged from 5 percent to 20
percent since november many schools
returned from the winter break online
only but here in washington and in new
york where positive tests have grown
from 3 percent to 33 percent schools are
open for business
new york's mayor insists that school is
the safest place for children
if you look
last year
2020
you witnessed that the transmission rate
was less than one percent inside a
school in the household it was over 15
percent back in washington president
biden ended with a plea for the 35
million eligible americans who remain
unvaccinated
please take advantage of what's
available
please
in a nation where one's view of
vaccination can depend on one's
political affiliation it seems certain
that that's a plea that at least for
some will fall on deaf ears john hendren
al jazeera washington